1886 a very ambitious and determined
lady named Minnie Schoenberg gave birth
to the first of five boys his name is
Leonard and he was followed by either
and Julius and Herbert and finally
Milton because her brother al Sheehan
was in show business as half of the
famous team of Gallagher and Sheehan she
felt that her sons deserved the same
fate so for the boys went along with her
wishes and along the way they changed
their names and they changed the world
of comedy
they were as revolutionary in their
approach to humor as a man named Karl
Marx was in his approach to philosophy
and politics and spending the day with
them at the races or a Night at the
Opera 87 minutes at the circus a 78
minutes waiting for room service or a
night in Casablanca you can count them
in is that they were on the screen but
you cannot count the laughs although the
world has paid tribute to them for over
45 years with its love its laughter and
his devotion tonight the Academy through
the Board of Governors is proud to pay
this tribute to Groucho Marx and the
Marx Brothers by presenting an honorary
award to them for their brilliance and
lasting contribution to the art of
motion pictures
I want to thank those who voted for me
to give this award I wish to hop on
Chico Hoover here to share with me this
great honor
I wish Margaret Dumont could be here too
she was a great straight woman for me
even though she never understood any my
jokes she used to say Julie what are
they living in but most of all I want to
thank my mother because without her we
never would have been anything and last
of all I'd like to thank M Fleming who
makes my life worth living and who
understands all my jokes